so in knapp 4 Minuten öffnen sich die
Türen neues Spiel neues Glück sein Sie
kreativ überraschen sie mich wir haben
schließlich einen Ruf zu verteidigen sie
wissen was die Kundschaft von uns
erwartet und in dem Zusammenhang möchte
ich mal lobend die Frau Kessler
erwähnen sie ist gestern lediglich auf
zwei Kundenkontakte gekommen und ist
beiöffnungszeit von 7 Uhr bis 20 Uhr ch
Frau Kessler einfach vor
ja und einer hat nur nach der Toilette
gefragt im Grunde genommen waren es also
nur anderthalb Kundenkontakte ja stimmt
da haben sie recht aber meine Herren
wollen wir das auf uns sitzen lassen
nein ich glaube nicht so in eineinhalb
Minuten öffnen die Türen sind Sie
bereit okay dann 3 2 ein
[Musik]
komme
hallo
hallo gibt's ja auch
jckapmen Zwölfer
deckenrolle Zwölfer Decken Rolle dass da
niemand ist denmer fragen könnte
hallo könnten Sie mir vielleicht bitte
weiterhelfen
hallo hallo gehen sie weg ich bin gar
nicht da aber ich sehe sie doch aber ich
sie sie
nicht grattelhuber ihr baumach wir sind
für Sie
da